we got so much more of Madison and we're
excited people being nice and our legal
eagle loses her case before that are
left like little babies this is your
bachelor season 24 episode 7 recap grab
your glasses it's time for roses and
Rose hi everybody it's me Lauren Zima
and I am wearing what might be my
chicest outfit
[Music]
why because we are back on track people
this show has returned to its former
glory
just the right amount of drama and fun
The Bachelor is back
I loved this episode everybody we got
down to our final four women and I loved
watching it the whole time what did you
think let me know in the comments below
but I am feeling chic I am feeling short
I am feeling show let's get to it in
honor of all the chic miss I'm actually
not drinking a rose a today I have gone
for a very special as sure donate I feel
like it goes with this outfit the entire
rabbits kind of the color of Chardonnay
okay so this is trophy thin I just love
this Chardonnay and recommended a heavy
pour to celebrate so
[Music]
this is why I should stick with the road
day it can't all be chic guys we got to
remember that we started back at
elevated ratchet you know it's sheiks
only now but there's still a little
ratchet in here we are now in Peru I
really loved it beautiful buildings
great cultural vibes and we're starting
off strong
we're FaceTime and Barb yeah Peters mom
was there on the FaceTime is she crying
Peter is she crying to zoom in zoom in
Peter Peter make make her face the whole
screen I can't see her she all right is
barb all right don't make barb cry again
Oh Oh cheers to barb
white as cold as it should be
at the end maybe that person just you
know they feel for me but now on the
same way and don't drink for every time
Peter talks through his biggest fear
this episode which is that someone who
he loves will not love him as much in
return a K and a brown trauma okay
I obviously fell for Hannah and I
thought that it was there between the
two of us but I didn't see it coming but
this is legit because some of these
women have shown Peter they have doubts
Kelly Victoria F very freakin much so
now the women are all hanging out
together which was so nice to see this
episode but was anyone else totally
taken aback to hear Madison talk I know
like you you haven't gotten a one-on-one
yet and I feel like mine was literally
years ago her voice is a totally
different octave than I was aware of
it's much lower
I suppose we believe heard Madison
speaking brief when she's giggling and
laughing with Peter things went from -
hey you guys we are on the same page
with that I knew Madison was from
Alabama but I'm not sure I was aware she
had an accent I feel like mine was
literally years ago she isn't barely bit
on the show then we get Madison in a
confessional for me marriage is such a
big deal and it's something that you do
one time and that is your person forever
has that ever happened normally we get
the women talking to camera quite a lot
this might be the first time we have
seen Madison in what they call an ITN in
the moment moment so things are going so
well it's so nice to see the women
talking to each other getting a break
from the cattiness and that Madison's in
a confessional again in a different
outfit time we're excited I like what I
just like there's so much Madison
[Music]
Madison I think you're a catch
Peter now poor Natasha is still there
hello hi my name is Natasha
but just like McKenna didn't get a one
one-on-one before Victoria
I've got her number two one-on-one well
Natasha is not even gonna get a solo not
even a 101 on one before Madison gets
another one I just have a lot on my
heart that I want to share with Peter
so now Madison's getting a second
one-on-one we're getting a third lucky
and a confessional they are making up
for lost time this place definitely a
huge huge huge huge step she goes on
their date and Peter says Maddie I
missed you our through and we did to
Peter and he says it's been too long
I'm through on yes it has drink every
time they talk about how long it's been
my best view it's you on but then it's
been a while now well we have a very fun
day planned for his little fishing
village oh and they're doing an explore
the local market date which I love these
are real dates where you have real
conversations and he deserves this hey
you know what notice
behind the way drink for every time
Peter needed his forehead bandage
removal approval to of this episode good
luck yeah
my god notice what you think okay thanks
it's kind of better thank you for his
going for and they've always seems close
but they got even closer drink every
time Peter and Madison we're clinging to
each other having her legs over mine and
just tangled up at each other it just
feels so right he was like I love being
tangled just so good and Madison was
like yes it just sounds different that I
thought it did she's great
they're clinging to each other because
it's been too long and I'm clinging to
this footage because this is my kind of
date everybody they walked around the
market and now they're on a boat
drinking as he has said before Peter
tells Madison he loves the validation
she's giving him she doesn't want me to
doubt anything about her and that
validation is it feels really good but
what I adored about this was Madison
gave Peter validation without having to
cry it's a good sign keep a smile on
what did you guys think of their date I
just found the whole thing as refreshing
as the Peruvian waters bountiful filled
with fish easy to catch and the catch at
this point I really don't understand how
Peter couldn't pick Madison she's the
only one he hasn't made major issues
with when you guys think let me know in
the comments below huh I hope everyone's
taking it super seriously because it is
a very serious week back at the
sleepover Hanna Anne and Kelsey are
talking about Madison and about how
she's really religious very religious
and that's something that's very
important to her this was so interesting
to me it made me realize that we really
don't know these women all that well and
I would like to like look at Hannah Ann
and Kelsey back in the beginning they
were at each other's throats over
champagne it's so nice to see these
friendships this is the first season in
a while when I've been kind of unaware
of who is even friends with who in the
cast lovely to see Hannah Ann and Kelsey
have moved on
tell me what you think and I gotta say
cheers - Kelsey at times she has said
some nonsensical stuff this season but
this comment made sense she said no
matter what your connection is with
somebody because
it doesn't matter how strong your
connection is with people sometimes some
things are just deal-breakers if certain
aspects of your life don't line up it's
kind of a make or break so the question
is is Peter religious enough for Madison
I'm not sure it was answered this week
but I think more to come
Natasha speaking of learning etosha
learns she's getting her first
one-on-one the books Explorer Peter at
this point I was worried for Natasha you
know weren't you guys it felt like too
little too late
of course Madison and Peeta are dancing
whatever I don't even care them racing
and at this point but this date really
looks great
the market the both live music now some
dinner great lighting beautiful people
perfect that means to have perfect I'm
so happy this is the show I love this
date is going really well peter is
asking sensical questions and Madison is
responding with clear comprehendible
answers I like to see like a future with
you and I see a life after this then
Maddie does tell Peter about her deep
faith she says that her religion pretty
much makes up everything about who she
is it's literally my whole life and like
all its like Who I am and this did feel
huge to me did you guys think Maddie
should have shared this with Peter
sooner and tell me how you felt about
Peters response I definitely have faith
I knew for that my faith can be stronger
I thought that it was genuine honest and
I don't think that their religion is
necessarily a complete roadblock at this
point well let me know in the comments
below and then Peter looks so nervous
he's really sweating he's really
swallowing what's gonna happen is he
gonna break up with her I suddenly got
scared but now things are still going
well
get our first falling in love with you
of the season from the lead anyway
Kelsey had said to PETA that she's
falling in love with him but from bade
are you guys
peter is falling in love with Madison
and she's the only person he's told that
to hmm I interviewed Peter just a few
days ago he told me that his frontrunner
was clear to him ACEF week 4 no matter
what you see in the editing of the show
so who do you think it is let me know in
the comments below shameless I kinda
thought she didn't say it back that was
interesting perhaps unexpected what did
you think let me know in the comments
below can things please not go poorly I
need things to keep going well and we're
in a really good place right now
either way Maddie gets a rose oh and it
isn't over this show is the gift that
keeps on giving then we get it against
the wall kiss I'm crazy back I'm so
happy it's time for Natasha's one-on-one
and they also have a market date where
they're gonna walk around in Turtle
mash'ems last night I am falling not
that I ever want to compare
relationships Peters comparing her to
Madison and he just sold Madison he was
falling in love with her I kind of had a
bad feeling about the whole thing didn't
you let me know the comments below by
the way a quick note for just enjoying
when the bachelor takes us around the
world I love hearing Peters speak
Spanish and I enjoyed the genuine joy
that he found when he came across a
desert that his grandmother used to make
this is my absolute favorite I just
thought it was great plus I love snacks
I wish I had one now
[Music]
you know what we're enjoying this so
much let's have some fun and just do
some quick don't drink Stu don't drink
for every dance natasha and peter are
gonna dance - don't drink for every time
Hannah Anne and Kelsey talk they've
really moved forward yeah no that's true
growth progress female friendships has
this even gotten chic love is a wild
ride
Peter Kelsey gets a one-on-one yes we
are in serious date mode this is episode
lots of ladies getting one-on-one except
for three of them okay Victoria and
Kelly are gonna be getting a three out
of one and that's where we're gonna get
the drug that we love so much the
balance has been restored to the
bachelor force I also kind of Star Wars
nerd I don't know if I ever told you
guys that but yeah mm-hmm
you will move yourself into the glass
there is no try do or do not there is no
try
there is there is no try that's not a
great your voice why you fail but we
still gotta finish Peter in Natasha's
date now it's the night time portion and
drink every time they say I feel like I
feel like we we do have a really strong
connection I feel like with you I feel
like I'm completely I feel like
[Applause]
to continue I feel like they're gonna
break up mm-hmm I should start doing my
drink voice like Yoda yeah Peter says
it's just a friendship with Natasha and
he ends it and drink every time
someone's not all that shocked Kelsey's
not shocked
Anna Ann's not all that shocked Peter's
not shocked honestly Natasha doesn't
seem that shocked
yes unexpected so it's fine oh by the
way a quick shout-out to the non word of
the week delivered by one of the ladies
we've had roughly one per episode in
unbelievably this week is coming from
our higher educated Kelly
she says Wendling things are Wendling
down and I think dwindling Wendling I'm
Windell in this wiring finding whatever
didn't see it coming from our highly
educated legal legal but you know
remember she's out of her hell of a
terror show I'm just gonna continue to
so Peter has sent Natasha home and we
think that Peter is alone but then this
show is the gift that keeps on giving
and it's given us some more people of
Oaxaca strap and really see and wearing
that with each of these relationships
I suppose they thought that Peter and
Natasha might dance to that orchestra's
music but instead he's just standing at
the balcony holding the Rose alone as
the orchestra plays
don't drink for every member of the
orchestra it's a full orchestra you guys
don't drink out we had violins violas
cellos bassist everybody was there all
right
no it's Kelly's one on one and you know
we always run to the lead but man
specially towards the end of the season
here where they're really feeling
invested but Kelly was running on a
downhill slope I mean she was really
running you know what I'm saying like
Kelly's a tall lady and she really had
some speed
she was really coming it beat her and
then she jumped of course for him to
catch her and I just thought God that
cut is still so fresh on his head haha I
mean he just got that bandage off as he
told us multiple times yeah man this is
off and everything and then they go
ATVing what's gonna be very talked wait
we're running yeah run up a mountain and
drink for everyone who was suffering in
this moment Peter's a little out of
breath Kelsey's definitely tired how
about our poor camera guy he's going up
that slope I'll get equipment but again
I'm happy things are going well Peters
asking intelligent questions Peter
actually answered kind of what you
envision Kelsey's giving understandable
answers I want to be able to work a
couple days a week but also be at home
oh well we're still gonna stick with the
theme of the season we get to the
nighttime portion of the date and
Kelsey's already crying I'm conversation
to change things Kelsey I'm not judging
you for crying you're allowed to be
emotional if that's the way that you
share your feelings but don't you ruin
that make up you've got a really good
smoky eye going Kelsey you're
unbelievable at contour don't ruin the
liner
next calcium Peter talking about her
family and again drink for all we're
learning Kelsey was in Chile a year ago
about a year ago when I was in Chile it
was going through a really hard time
he'll see us sisters my sisters didn't
want to go Kelsey's talking to her
estranged father and her mom is unaware
we've been in communication since but
issues with my mom does enough Wow
I'm here for it we are learning so much
about these women tonight oh and Kelsey
gets a rose Kelsey's going to hometowns
what do you think let me know in the
comments below
Peter says he loves where they're at
even though their relationship isn't
conventional I mean to say the least you
guys
Kelsey went from champagne gate on night
one Tom tell us I mean what oh right
what a ride what a run what a run up a
steep hill only to fall over maybe I
don't know I hope please let's stay on
our feet okay so Callie Hannah Ann and
Victoria are going on that three on one
and just as almost every woman has had
an angry turn at some point during this
season unfortunately now it's Kelly's
time in the end and Victoria
our children she gets a little bit mean
she calls the other women children I'm
on a different like emotional level and
I'm the only one when sure enough to be
like actually ready for a relationship
she literally takes a nap on the date
[Music]
did she actually say that she's an
attorney I mean look at me I'm an
attorney the other girls what are they
and what are the other women
what are they ready for Rose give it to
me she says at 23 that Hannah and she's
just not in the right phase of her life
to be in a relationship I couldn't
disagree more we started having
relationships probably in our teenage
years and learning and growing and
evolving from there and I don't really
think that your readiness for a
relationship is about age it's about the
amount of maturity that you've gained
through the life experiences that you've
had Victoria she's always breaking down
and crying though Kelly does then say
that Victoria F is a hot mess is always
upset all the time and well
[Music]
literally they feel sick oh my god
[Music]
honestly I need to know if Kelly has
ever seen the show at this point you
guys it's so funny in the beginning of
the date she tells Peter you're making
us walk really far you're making us walk
awfully far
I mean Kelsey's over here running
towards Peter and Kelly's like could the
car dropped us off a little closer
you're making us walk awfully far I
don't disagree with her it's just she's
so out of her comfort zone but there are
two other women on the date and cheers
to Hannah and I've got to say I've had a
problem in the past with Hannah and not
really sharing and explaining her
feelings to Peter maybe she's somebody
who communicates better through the
written word she wrote down a list of
reasons that she feels connected to
Peter you make time for me you make me
feel like the only girl here and I liked
that cheer so that Hannah and it was
great and it's great you know and let's
give Victoria half credit for staying on
brand she's melting down and drink for
every time that Kelly is over confident
about the outcome of this three on one
date I'm definitely confident give me a
rose chop-chop let's go I think it's
just super obvious for the best match
Kelly says she feels confident about
this she's got it all locked up because
Peter isn't going to like all of this
drama but he's able to see that I have
like a good head on my shoulders that
I'm not just gonna make drama yeah so
Kelly's gonna go home yeah by the way I
did ask Peter about this pattern of
giving women roses after they break down
and you can find that interview up at
EDM I'm calm shameless plug mm-hmm
Kelly finally talks to Peter on this
three on one date and tells them that
relationships can be easy like it can be
easy and so it could be fun I agree with
Kelly on this you guys and it opened up
my eyes a little bit to Peter
relationships don't have to be hard to
be serious I agree but I think maybe
Peter thinks that they do
let me know in the comments below
Victoria and then Victoria F says
something that absolutely blows my mind
she she tells Peter that every time
they're together he he it's like every
single time we're together I feel like
you're always in a mood yeah I wrote
down three words this is toxic oh god
you guys and the weird thing is that
Victoria F does on some level appear to
be aware of herself she tells Kelly that
Kelly and Peter's connection is so easy
I think with your connection with him is
so easy and fluent it's just not always
easy every time someone says easy Pierre
has kind of an easy decision
so Peter pulls Victoria out aside and
Hannah and Kelly think that that means
Victoria was going home but now I don't
know if Peters holding a rose and
actually what he tells her is that good
I don't mind a little crazy
he doesn't mind a little crazy out we
know that Peter and then he appreciates
that she opened up I appreciate you're
okay enough today what has she opened up
anyway except this dress even though
this was an amazing episode that really
tracks does it hurt
[Music]
I'm fine it's fine
sheep only I suppose the question at
this point is while Peter doesn't mind
crazy I don't mind a little crazy will
he propose too crazy let me know in the
comments below also Hannah Anne gets a
rose as we predicted
I do wish Kelly had gone out on a better
note before that are left like little
babies they don't really know who they
are it was kind of a dark limo ride but
all my love to Kelly hi everybody quick
vlog to discuss Kelly's eggs that a
little bit more because a lot of chatter
surrounding things that she allegedly
appeared to be saying about the other
women that seemed very out of character
for our beloved Kelly I will say that no
matter what went down I really wish that
each woman hadn't had to have had a
villainous turn at some point this
season you know we like to root for
people that's part of the balance of the
show it makes me look very forward to
the women tell all I want to ask a lot
of questions and I want to hear a lot
discussed love you guys
and I appreciated the nice hugs at the
end here all of the ladies hugging
Hannah and hugging her former champ
enemy Kelsey everyone just doing well
everybody we have our final four and
while some of the women in that group
might be unexpected we must remain
composed we must stay chic so let me
know what you think of the final four in
the comments below and in the trailer
for next week Madison tells Peter that
she's a virgin I am saving myself for
marriage were you shocked by that please
tell me your thoughts also in the
trailer Peter reveals that he did get
intimate with someone else
specifically six days prior tell me your
feelings and also coming up of course
Victoria f is crying and freaking out
done but I don't know at the end of the
day do we appreciate consistency oh you
guys I'm available on Instagram Twitter
and the app cameo if you'd like a very
chic personal message from me bye
[Music]